WHERE WE FIND OUT FOR CERTAIN
WHICH OF TWO FOX NEWS
PROFESSIONALS HAVE BEEN PAYING
MORE ATTENTION AT WORK THAN
PLAYING VIDEO GAMES.
OUR DEFENDING CHAMPION, OUR
REPORTER FOR FOX NEWS HEADLINES
24/7 BEING CHALLENGED BY A
VETERAN.
>> IF I LOSE DON'T TELL MY BOSS
I WASN'T PAYING ATTENTION.
>> Tucker: HAND ON BUZZARDS.
QUESTION TO BUZZ IN.
A WRONG ANSWER SUBTRACTS.
ARE YOU READY?
>> READY.
>> Tucker: QUESTION ONE, A WORLD
LEADER STRIPPED DOWN TO HIS
TRUNKS TAKING A REFRESHING AND
RELIGIOUS ICE BATH.
WHICH LEADER WAS IT?
PETER.
>> PRESIDENT PUTIN.
>> Tucker: VLADAMIR PUTIN.
HOW DARE YOU USE THOSE WORDS.
LET'S ROLL TAPE.
>> VLADAMIR PUTIN HAS TAKEN HIS
SHIRT OFF AGAIN.
WHY DID YOU DO THIS, MR. VLAD.
>> PRESIDENT PUTIN MADE HIS WAY
TO THE LAKE IN FUR COAT AND
BOOTS AND STRIPPED DOWN TO HIS
BATHING TRUNKS.
>> Tucker: DID YOU KNOW THAT?
>> I DID.
THE AMBASSADOR ALSO DID THAT AS
WELL.
HALF POINT SITUATION?
>> Tucker: I'D LOAF
>> Tucker: I'D LOA
>> Tucker: I'D LOVE
>> Tucker: I'D LOVE TO
>> Tucker: I'D LOVE TO.
>> Tucker: A NEWS HOST JUST
RELEASED A FOLK ROCK BALLOT
INSPIRED BY A WOMEN'S MARCH.
WHICH CABLE HOST WAS IT?
PETER.
>> MORNING JOE SCARBOROUGH.
>> Tucker: I THINK IT'S BRIAN
FOR THE RECORD.
WE'LL FIND OUT ON THE TAPE.
>> IT'S LIKE WHEN YOUR BOSS
COMES IN WEARING AN UGLY SHIRT.
DON'T WANT TO BE THE ONE TELLING
POMPOUS TALENT, JOE SCARBOROUGH,
THINK HE'S A POP STAR.
♪
>> Tucker: AL SHARPTON CUT AN
ALBUM.
LITTLE KNOWN FACT.
NOT BAD.
RESEARCHERS IN CHINA ANNOUNCED
A TERRIFYING SCIENTIFIC
BREAKTHROUGH.
THEY'VE SUCCESSFULLY CLONED
WHICH ANIMAL?
>> A MONKEY.
>> Tucker: I DON'T KNOW THE
ANSWER SO WE'LL ROLL TAPE.
>> GAME OF CLONE.
A MAJOR BREAKTHROUGH AS CHINESE
SCIENTISTS CLONE MONKEYS INCHING
ONE STEP CLOSER TO HUMAN
CLONING.
>> AS A CURIOUS GEORGE FAN --
>> Tucker: 30 YEARS FROM NOW IT
WILL BE SEEN AS A TURNING POINT.
QUESTION FOUR, PRIOR TO LAST
SUNDAY'S BIG FOOTBALL GAME,
POLICE IN PHILADELPHIA USED
WHICH FOOD PRODUCT ON TELEPHONE
POLES TO KEEP WILD EAGLES' FANS
FROM CLIMBING THEM?
>> CRISCO.
>> THE COPS IN PHILLY GREASED
THE POLES WITH CRISCO TO KEEP
PEOPLE FROM CLIMBING THEM AFTER
IT DIDN'T WORK.
>> THE CRISCO COPS.
>> AND THEN IT RAINED AND IT'S
WE'RE IN SUDDEN DEATH.
EACH OF YOU HAS TWO POINTS.
>> CAGE MATCH --
>> COULD BE.
>> Tucker: LAST QUESTION.
ARE YOU BOTH READY?
THE WINNER WILL EMERGE FROM THE
ROUND.
A DOZEN OR SO CAMELS WERE
DISQUALIFIED FROM A MAJOR CAMEL
BEAUTY PAGEANT IN SAUDI ARABIA,
NOT A MINOR CAMEL BEAUTY PAGEANT
A REAL ONE AFTER IT WAS
DISCOVERED THE ANIMALS HAD BEEN
>> HGH.
>> Tucker: HUMAN GROWTH HORMONE?
>> THAT WOULD BE A VERY SERIOUS
ADVANTAGE FOR A CAMEL.
WE'LL ROLL THE TAPE AND SEE IF
IT'S HGH.
>> THE COUNTRY HAS CAMEL BEAUTY
PATH
PAT
PAGEANTS BUT THERE'S SCANDAL IN
THE WORLD OF CAMEL BEAUTY.
A DOZEN ANIMALS HAVE BEEN
DISQUALIFIED AFTER JUDGES FOUND
THEY RECEIVED BOTOX.
APPARENTLY BOTOX CAN MAKE A
CAMEL'S HEAD LOOK BIGGER AND
LIPS DROOPIER.
>> DIDN'T YOU JUST IS A YOU
DIDN'T KNOW ANYTHING ABOUT THIS?
PETER, BRAVE EFFORT BUT CARLEY
REMAINS -- SO NOW, LOOK AT THAT,
CARLEY YOU WIN ANOTHER COVETED
MOUTH-BREATHING MUG AND THE
ADULATIONS OF OUR FANS.
PETER, THAT WAS A VALIANT
ATTEMPT.
>> THANK YOU.
I'LL JUST NOT TELL ANYBODY I DID
THE QUIZ TONIGHT.
>> WE CAN SHARE THE MUG.
>> Tucker: PAY ATTENTION TO THE